we have new insight into the
decades-long case of a missing girl that
stunned investigators back in 1981
13-year old married a mysteriously
vanished for a home in Seaside
California her parents said she ran away
but her sisters suspected she was
murdered
Mary's disappearance went unreported for
more than a decade and once authorities
became involved it took another 15 years
to close the case Maureen Maher
investigates for this week's 48 hours in
2002 Seaside California police captain
steve sarcone had a baffling case on his
hands what happened to 13 year old
married a Mary Louise day was a girl
that lived in Seaside in about 1981 she
disappeared
what do you mean she disappeared she
disappeared off the face of the earth
there is no record that her mother
Charlotte Huell or stepfather William
ever reported her missing it's hard to
believe allowing a child to walk away or
child go missing and it's not reported I
can't remember a time when a child was
not reported by the parents younger
sister Sherri Cal Garo who was 10 when
Mary vanished turned to middle sister
Kathy for answers laying about one night
was cathing I asked her what happened
with Mary you know and she was like Shh
don't say anything we're not allowed to
talk about Mary when Sheri grew up she
filed a missing persons report by the
time Seaside police launched its
investigation there was little to go on
it was a very hard case to deal with
other than the family nobody knew she
was gone Mary's mother told detectives
that her daughter ran away as she had so
many times before
tracing Mary's last-known whereabouts
lead detective Joe Bertina took Kathy
back to her childhood home she told
Bertina that she saw their stepfather
William beat Mary
[Music]
detectives began to believe that William
had murdered Mary William told me that
he didn't kill Mary Day but his wife
told him that he was possessed that
night and that he had a demon inside of
him a team of cadaver dogs were brought
to the home just searched for human
remains as the dogs went into the
backyard
they each hit on one particular spot
near a tree we started today and as we
dug I saw a little girl shoe but there
was no body
still the investigators were confident
in their homicide case until a year
later when it took an unexpected turn I
got a phone call he told me hey captain
he says he's sitting down he said gotta
let you know that they say that they
they found Mary day and Marine Walker
joins us now from Chicago Marine good
morning I you know I don't want you to
give up the mystery but I gotta ask you
this grown woman who claims to be the
real Mary day
is she the real Mary day well that is
the mystery and you'll find that
detectives and family members Toni they
were very skeptical when this woman
shows up out of nowhere and adding to
that skepticism is the fact that just
before police found her three weeks
before she was discovered by police she
had a state ID issued to her and the
timing was so coincidental that just
added to the skepticism of who is this
woman in Arizona huh and you actually
met her what did she have to say
yeah scepter five years of trying to
chase down this story the story has been
decades long we've been looking at it
since about 2012 she did say to us that
she was adamant that she was the real
married a Marine I so appreciate good TV
well we're all sheltering at home so
thank you very much for this and that
Marines report if you want to check it
out along with me
it will be Saturday night it's called
whatever happened to married day you can
tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central right
here of course on CBS